OK, now let's talk about Donald Trump's press
secretary, Kaley McEnany, defending Donald
Trump's white power tweet.
This is just completely unconscionable.
Yesterday, I told you that Donald Trump put
out a tweet over the weekend, which included
a video in which one of his supporters yells
white power at anti Trump protesters.
Donald Trump's exact tweet was, quote, Thank
you to the great people of the villages.
The radical left do nothing.
Democrats will fall in the fall.
Corrupt Joe is shot.
See you soon.
Here is the video that Trump shared with that
comment.
You'll notice that about eight seconds in,
you hear this guy yelled white power twice.
So first, earlier yesterday on Fox and Friends,
Donald Trump's press secretary, Kaley McEnany,
said Trump didn't hear the white power part.
Now, that's weird because the White Power
Party's eight seconds into video.
But that's what Kelly McCann and he said yesterday
on Fox and Friends.
The president tweeted out that tweet yesterday
and took it down.
If you played it, it was a guy saying white
supremacy, it was another woman or white,
you know, white power, white power.
And then the woman was yelling obscenities
cause she doesn't like the president.
That's some of the guy as they were in the
parade down at the village as what's the president's
response?
Did he know what he was tweeting when he did
he accidentally tweet that?
So the president did not hear that phrase
in that portion of the video.
And when it was signaled to him that this
was in there, he took that tweet down.
Now, there's already a lie there.
Reports are not that Trump immediately took
it down as soon as he found out about the
white power thing.
The reports are that aides spent three hours
trying to convince Trump to take the video
down, despite making it clear up front that
there's a guy saying white power in the video.
So Kaylee's saying, oh, as soon as Trump found
out about white power, he took it right down.
That's a lie.
Three hours is not immediately taking it down.
But then she says, hey, you know, he does
stand with his supporters at the villages.
Even the guy who said white power, even if
I guess he doesn't stand by the white power
comment.
Take a look at that.
But he made very clear to me that he stands
with the people of the villages are great
seniors, men and women in the villages who
support this president.
He stands for them.
And his point in tweeting out that video was
to stand with his supporters who are oftentimes
demonized.
So we didn't hear that portion.
He took it down.
But he does stand with the men and women of
the villages.
We're truly living in some of the stupidest
times that I can remember.
And I guess by saying Trump still supports
his supporters, but not white power, she's
saying she still supports the guy who yelled
white power.
Just not yelling white power, I guess.
I mean, it's completely incoherent.
That was on Fox later yesterday.
Kaley did a press briefing and during the
press briefing, the question was asked, did
Trump even watch the video?
Because the white power part.
It's not like two minutes in.
It's eight seconds in.
And Kaley says, yes, he watched it, but he
didn't hear anybody say white power.
Thank you, Kelly.
I want to go back to the president meeting
yesterday and then for a power that was.
Now, as the president retreats, other people's
videos without knowing the full content of.
We did not hear that particular phrase when
he tweeted out the video.
And he did and he did not hear that particular
phrase.
Trump watched the video but didn't hear the
shouts of white power.
Eight seconds in.
I guess that's the story they're going for.
So I my message with all of this.
Listen, you all know Trump lies all the time
and his administration lies all the time.
My message to you is how stupid does he think
his followers are?
If these are the explanations they give.
Oh, Trump wasn't briefed on Russian bounties.
We now have three credible reports that he
was briefed as long as a U.
More than a year ago, 15 months ago.
Oh, Trump didn't hear anybody yell white power.
Eight seconds in the Trump.
Watch the video.
Yeah.
He watched the video.
He just didn't hear anybody yell white power.
The disdain that they have for their supporters
is stunning.
If they believe their supporters will fall
for this stuff.
And what's sad is a lot of the supporters
do.
And that is something that, you know, when
when when we go and we think about voting
in November, we have to remember that even
if we're not falling for these obvious lies
from Trump supporters, from Trump meant to
trick his supporters, the supporters are falling
for it.
We're going to talk about some more of those
lies later about protests and corona virus
cases and the like.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman for
continued coverage of my very safe, socially
distant vacation here in Martha's Vineyard.
We'll take a quick break and be back with
so much more right after this.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot.com.